[Applaus]
[Musik]
so gut wie die ganze westliche welt will
aufgrund von wladimir putins
angriffskrieg auf die ukraine von
russischen tattoolos kommen und alle
anderen erdöl fördernden ländern freuen
sich schon wie die schneekönige auf die
riesigen mehreinnahmen die ihn ins haus
stehen wenn sie das russische öl
ersetzen werden alle nein nicht alle da
ist ein land das sich verbissen dagegen
wehrt mehr geld zu verdienen heute
wollen wir ihnen genau dieses land
reisen in einem staat der schon seit so
langer zeit unter so krasser und für uns
eigentlich unvorstellbare politischer
korruption leidet dass er selbst seine
größte wirtschaftliche chance seit
jahrzehnten einfach so in den wind
schlagen wird
[Musik]
also oder amigos willkommen in mexiko wo
das volk derart durch korruption und
schwerkriminalität verbürgt ist dass ich
selbst ein politiker wie andrés manuel
lópez obrador konstant hohe
popularitätswerte er fort aber lopez
operateur emfis com auch kurs am loh
genannt ist nicht irgendwer er ist der
preisträger des visual politik antwort
2021 diesen preis der schande haben wenn
aufgrund all der misserfolge
ideologischen gaga politik verliehen die
er in den wenigen jahren an der spitze
der regierung zu verantworten habe das
video zur preisverleihung werde ich euch
natürlich verlinken halo ist aber kein
klassischer populist der schreibung
schimpft er hat die vielleicht
wichtigste eigenschaft eines
erfolgreichen politikers er weiß wie er
den bürgern genau das bieten kann was
sie zu einem bestimmten zeitpunkt am
meisten wollen früher präsidentin
mexikos haben geld verprasst ohne ende
aber am loh hat bewiesen dass er anders
ist er reist in der economy class er hat
die präsidentenresidenz los pinos in
eine art kulturzentrum verwandelt und
auch das präsenten flugzeug eine boing
787 hat er auch verzichtet und niemand
weiß übrigens etwas mit dir anzufangen
der punkt ist aber dass solche aktion
die sympathie der bevölkerung wecken und
versteh mich nicht falsch diese dinge
mögen in ordnung sein besonders wenn wir
den trotzigen lebensstil berücksichtigen
der typisch für mexikanische präsidenten
und spitzenpolitiker ist aber das
problem besteht darin dass man dieses
sympathischen züge dazu missbrauchen
kann um alle möglichen schädlichen
regierungsmaßnahmen zu übertünchen und
zu rechtfertigen
und noch schlimmer ist es wenn die
unterstützung der bevölkerung dazu
genutzt wird zu vertuschen dass es der
wirtschaft wirklich mies geht trotz der
international verurteilung der
russischen invasion in der ukraine hat
nun erklärt dass mexiko keine direkten
sanktionen gegen russlands da hängen
wird er wolle gute beziehungen zu allen
regierungen der welt haben gut eine
solch optimistische haltung nehmen so
einige staatschefs ein wenn sie vor
allem ihr eigenes land an die erste
stelle setzen und vielleicht einfach von
beiden seiten profitieren möchten aber
bei am loh geht es nicht darum dass sein
land irgendwie profitiert ist ein
opportunismus entspringt einfach
ideologie getriebener klientel politik
und selbst der etage aber ja das ist
durchaus etwas was in mexiko eine
unrühmliche tradition hat
nur einen tag nachdem die us regierung
sanktionen gegen russische reporter
verhängt hatte und diplomatische
bemühungen einleitete um auf der ganzen
welt erst als lieferanten für russisches
erdöl zu finden darunter natürlich auch
das direkte nachbarland mexiko
bekräftigte der mexikanische präsident
seine strikte maßgabe die nationale
produktion streng auch nicht mehr als
zwei millionen barrel pro tag zu
limitieren angeblich damit der reserven
für künftige generationen nicht
erschöpft werden aber ist dieses
argument valide nun tatsache ist dass
lópez obrador trotz der hohen
kriminalitätsrate unter kränkelnden
wirtschaft eine sehr hohe
zustimmungsrate unter den mexikanischen
wlan hat praktisch jeden tag hält der
präsident zu seinen eigenen um
pressekonferenzen ab dem mehr als zwei
stunden dauern da stellt sich die frage
ob der präsident eines landes wie mexiko
nichts besseres zu tun hat es sichtlich
nicht seht euch einfach mal folgendes an
[Musik]
eine handvoll worte in 90 sekunden bei
solange pressekonferenzen weiß man
manchmal gar nicht was man sagen soll
aber warum sprechen wir bei visual
politik gerade jetzt über mexiko und am
nun der globale erdölmarkt das anders
als der für erdgas viel stärker
miteinander gekoppelte und entwicklung
in amerika durchaus auch erheblichen
einfluss auf die preise in europa und
dieser leutselige opa der wenn er will
auch nicht und sogar liebenswert sein
kann regiert an 126 millionen lang
welches mal der zweitgrößte
erdölproduzent der welt war direkt an
die größte gruppe macht der welt grenzt
und es trotzdem nicht schafft auf die
beine zu kommen und ich rate euch nicht
unvorsichtig zu sein denn am loh so
harmlos er auch auf außenstehende wirken
mag führt die sogenannte transformation
mexikos durch ein politischer plan der
darin besteht ihre formen seiner
vorgänger zu beenden aufzuheben und
umzukehren und seine eigene agenda
knallhart in allen bereichen des staates
durchzusetzen
das problem ist dass andere agenda sehr
viel mit der typischen
lateinamerikanischen politik zu tun hat
die sich immer wieder als wortlos erwies
und in der regel dazu führte dass
produktive investitionen abgeschreckt
oder erstickt wurden genau das passiert
jetzt im energiesektor und zwar gleich
doppelt zum einen ist da die strom für
form und zum anderen die richtung die
die staatliche ölgesellschaft pemex
unter dieser präsidentschaft
eingeschlagen hat deswegen wollen wir in
diesem video harmlos energiereform etwas
genauer unter die lupe nehme was
passiert gerade in mexikos energie
sektor worin besteht an los strom reform
und was noch wichtiger ist wie können
sich all diese maßnahmen auf mexikos
wirtschaft auswirken heute werden wir
hier auch visuell politik diese fragen
natürlich beantworten und zwar zuerst
wie immer mit einem kurzen blick in die
geschichte
das staatsmonopol
[Musik]
noch ein jahrhundert war mexiko der
zweitgrößte erdölproduzent der welt nur
übertroffen von mit vereinigten staaten
zu dieser zeit wurde der sektor von
ausländischen unternehmen dominiert die
als türen der compagnia mexikaner ella
die acht war von der britisch
niederländischen royal dutch shell
übernommen wollen es gab auch viele us
unternehmen die street lichter grenze
tätig waren sie verloren jedoch bald das
interesse an dem mexikanischen vorkommen
die briten begannen das öl im nahen
osten auszubeuten oder die amerikaner in
venezuela das problem für diese
unternehmen war nämlich dass die
arbeiter bewegung eine der säulen war
auf die sich der damalige präsident
lazarow cardenas stützte als sie ins
land der azteken kamen hatten die
ölfirmen keine ahnung in welche massen
sie da geraten waren
im jahr 1938 schwarz ein arbeitskampf
auf die politische bühne über als die
fünf türme urteil des obersten
gerichtshofs zu gunsten der forderungen
der arbeiter nicht zu befolgen diese
arroganz der ausländischen unternehmen
die versuchten sich vor der einhaltung
des urteils zu drücken müsste einen
streit um die souveränität des ganzen
landes aus präsident anas erkannte seine
chance und griff direkt in die
angelegenheit ein er verfügte die
verstaatlichung der ölindustrie und drei
monate später verkündete er die gründung
von petroleos mexicanos pemex des
staatsunternehmens dass das monopol für
die ausbeutung und verwaltung der
ölfelder des landes erhielt das ausland
ließ mexiko diese enteignungs maßnahme
problemlos durchgehen und warum nun
sagen wir einfach dass die vereinigten
staaten und das vereinigte königreich
und 40er jahren andere viel wichtigere
sorgen hatten als mexiko die rechnung
dafür zu präsentieren darüber hinaus
haben der zweite weltkrieg und das
wirtschaftswachstum der nachkriegszeit
die nachfrage nach erstem stark erhöht
so dass die verstaatlichung ein
perfektes geschäft war denn der öl
sektor war nicht der einzige
energiesektor in dem präsent cardenas
eingriff zuvor hatte er sich bereits in
den stromsektor eingemischt
[Musik]
um 0.37 gründete cardenas der zentrale
staatliche energieversorger kommission
der alde elektrizität kurz cfk sein
zweck weise mit öffentlichen auftrag
ausschließlich auf der grundlage
technokratischer prinzipien zu arbeiten
das ziel den höchsten möglichen ertrag
zu den geringstmöglichen kosten zu
erzielen das führt dazu dass private
unternehmen nur an den profitabelsten
gebieten interessiert waren den
wichtigsten städten und
industriegebieten und
[Musik]
so blieben dem staatlichen bundes
elektrizitätsversorger nur die
ländlichen und abgelegenen gebiete und
ganz offensichtlich hat dieses system
nicht funktioniert es führte zum ruin
des staatsunternehmens und obendrein war
mehr als die hälfte der mexikaner immer
noch ohne stromanschluss tja und wie hat
die mexikanische regierung dieses
problem eurer meinung nach lösen wollen
wie wäre es zum beispiel mit einer
privatisierung des marktes die den
wettbewerb fördert und investitionen
anregt nun nichts dergleichen es
passiert 1960 schloss präsident an soll
vor lopez matthäus die verstaatlichung
des gesamten stroms sektors ab und was
du hast zunächst schien auch das gar
nicht mal so schlecht zu laufen mexiko
hatte mehr als genug ressourcen und mit
den fehlentscheidungen fertig zu werden
und riesiges und beziehungen für den
stromverbrauch und die ganze wirtschaft
aufrecht zu erhalten vergesst nicht dass
länder mit erdöl damals die neureichen
auf der internationalen bühne waren und
das war seit den 70er jahren noch mehr
der fall denn die ölpreis krisen von
1971 und 79 trieben den ölpreis in die
höhe und vervielfachten die
exporteinnahmen von pemex
darüber hinaus wurde 1979 der cantarell
komplex eines der größten ölfelder welt
in betrieb genommen das problem war nur
dass die aufeinanderfolge mexikanischen
regierungen die vollständige kontrolle
über die ölgesellschaft hatten und sie
nicht gerade sagen wir mal mit einer
unternehmerischen mentalität führten im
gegenteil sie belasteten sie mit
zahlreichen steuern und abgaben um die
staatskasse zu füllen dadurch hatte
pemex viel weniger mittel hin zu
investieren und zu expandieren
[Musik]
der kantor l komplex erreichte im jahr
2004 die spitze seine fördermenge dieses
jahr war auch das höchste sonja in der
geschichte von pemex 3,4 millionen
barrel rohöl pro tag seitdem ist sie ja
zu jahr gesunken und lag im jahr 2020
nur noch bei der hälfte die regierung
brachte sich angesichts des rapiden
niedergangs von cantarell also zu
investitionen auf aber wir wären in
mexiko wenn die therapie nicht schlimmer
ausgefallen wäre als die krankheit an
sich per max investiert das war zwischen
2008 und 2012 70 milliarden dollar in
die exploration und förderung von rohöl
und das klingt dann nicht als super
schließlich ist es immer gut in die
zukunft investieren allerdings braucht
man auch etwas verstand dafür und kann
nicht einfach so drauflos investieren
nur weil es in den verkaufsprospekten so
toll aussieht das problem war nämlich
dass durch eine vollkommene kopflose
investitionsstrategie das meiste geld in
bereiche floss auf die packs technisch
überhaupt nicht vorbereitet war
[Musik]
die low tech firma wollte gleich von
null auf hundert sprengen
tiefseebohrungen und fracking wahren hit
also wurde alles gekauft was nicht bei
drei auf den bäumen war und das desaster
war garantiert und damit das alles noch
nicht schlimm genug ist wurde
investitionen hauptsächlich aus schulden
statt aus den laufenden einnahmen
getätigt weil die mexikanische regierung
nicht bereit war auf ihre regelmäßigen
zahlungen ins staatssäckel zu verzichten
das ergebnis die krise von pemex wurde
durch alle diese miserablen
investitionsentscheidungen noch
verschärft und wenn wir zu all dem noch
die korruption hinzurechnen jedes
unternehmen jahrzehntelang herstellt und
entscheidungen die er politisch als
geschäftlich motiviert waren und wie zum
beispiel dazu führten dass die
ölgesellschaft vielen der mitarbeiter
ist nötig beschäftigte dann haben wir es
mit einem moloch zu tun der bis zum hals
in schulden steckt während die förderung
zurückgeht
es war klar dass das einstige juwel
mexikos völlig abzustürzen drohte und
dass sich viele dinge ändern mussten und
das noch zu verhindern dummerweise wurde
diese aufgabe keinen geringeren
übertragen als einer der korruptesten
und inkompetenten regierungen in der
geschichte mexikos und das will schon
was heißen wir sprechen von der
regierung von enrique peña nieto eine
regierung auf die murphys gesetz wie
maßgeschneidert zu sein scheint eine
klares die esta wie sie im buche steht
egal um was ist gegen jede maßnahme war
durch pleiten pech und pannen
gekennzeichnet auch wenn die idee der
reform an sich in die richtige richtung
zielte denn letztlich ist ist ein
kleines wunder was bei dem ganzen
herauskam tatsache ist nämlich dass die
energiereform von 2030 das staatliche
monopol von pemex im ölsektor beendete
und in für private investitionen
eröffnete ausländischen unternehmen
durften intransparenten online
übertragenen auktionen angebote für die
übernahme der erkundung und förderung
von öl- feldern abgeben die reform
machte auch den weg frei für die
reduzierung der zahl der max
beschäftigten die von 151.000 jahr 2030
auf derzeit 120.000 gesuchten ist
insgesamt wurden 90 auktionen
durchgeführt wird im juli 2018 als anno
die wahl gewarnt gestoppt wurden
die bisherige bilanz ist es 111 felder
allen diesen auktion verkauft worden
sind und auf 34 bereits mit der
förderung begonnen wurde bislang wurden
auch 18 milliarden dollar investiert und
der anteil des mexikanischen staates an
den öleinnahmen in den verträgen
festgelegt wurde liegt bei etwa 74
prozent und das ist einer der höchsten
der welt aber was bedeutet das alles nun
im grunde hat diese reform
milliardenschwere investitionen von
ausländische unternehmen angezogen
private unternehmen die er gelte die
erkundung förderung von öl riskieren
aber dann den großteil der einnahmen aus
der produktion an den mexikanischen
staat abführen und das alles ohne dass
die mexikanische regierung einen
einzigen peso investieren muss klingt
doch nach einem guten geschäft für
mexiko nicht wahr wie immer gibt es
jemanden der anderer meinung ist und
diese andere meinung hat amnog schon
immer vertreten auch als dann noch
oppositionsführer war
[Musik]
ramelow leistete heftigen widerstand
gegen die energiereform von fenja netto
als guter populist ging er sogar soweit
zu versprechen dass ein referendum
abhalten würde damit sich das volk zur
reform äußern kann aber wie ihr wisst
ist wahlkampf die eine sache und
regieren eine ganz andere im dezember
2018 wurde am nur als präsident mexikos
vereidigt es ist also genug zeit
vergangen um bilanz zu ziehen also was
ist das ergebnis der energiepolitik
dieses präsidenten
[Musik]
nicht gerade raffiniert
[Applaus]
lópez obrador hat volksabstimmungen
aller art durchgeführt egal ob es mal um
den bau einer eisenbahnlinie ging oder
um einen flughafen aber das versprochene
referendum zur energiereform nein
ausgerechnet das wurde niedrig geführt
es wurde wohl irgendwie von dessen
vielleicht hat das damit zu tun dass
pécs der regierung weiterhin sehr viel
kopfzerbrechen bereitet denn obwohl am
loh über den staatlichen ölkonzern
spricht als wäre er das kronjuwel
mexikos sieht die realität ganz anders
aus die jahre vergehen und die verluste
steigen und steigen und das ist
eigentlich schon ein ziemliches stück
denn die förderkosten für ein barrel
rohöl betragen in mexiko im durchschnitt
7 dollar und verkauft werden kann es für
mindestens das zehnfache des rätsels
lösung liegt in der unglaublichen
administrativen ineffizienz korruption
und den gewaltigen belastungen auflagen
und steuern mit denen der mexikanische
staat pemex regelrecht die luft zum
atmen abschwört aber auch dies hat
wieder eine überforderte ursache der
staat kann nämlich gar nicht anders ein
drittel der öffentlichen ausgaben wird
aus den einnahmen des staatlichen
ölkonzerns getragen eine 126 millionen
volkswirtschaft die sich von einem
einzigen kranken und korrupte moloch
abhängig gemacht hatte pemex eines der
zehn am höchsten verschuldeten
unternehmen der welt wir sprechen von
einer verschuldung von mehr als 100
milliarden dollar eine verschuldung die
jedes jahr neue historische rekorde
aufstellt
[Musik]
rosa am loh seine stunde gekommen weil
der staatlichen ölgesellschaft macht
hart durchzugreifen als erstes ließ ein
neues treibstoff gesetz verabschieden
das pemex auf dem tankstellenmarkt
begünstigen sollen bei der öffnung für
ausländische investitionen mexikanischen
ölfeld ersetzte alu darauf die bereits
vergebenen verträge überprüfen um
festzustellen ob sie durch korruption zu
stande kamen außerdem wurden die wir
bereits gesehen haben die auktionen
verehrte förderrechte von dem moment an
ausgesetzt als er die wahlen gewann dies
alles mögen legitime und vielleicht auch
noch konstruktive schritte gewesen sagen
das gefährlichste von mexiko ist jedoch
dass seine regierung lässt das heißt
noch einen schritt weiter gehen will sie
ist zum beispiel direkt gegen die
interessen eines konsortiums vorgegangen
dass bereits 325 millionen dollar in
mexiko investiert hat und von der
us-firma taylors energie geleitet wird
das ergebnis dieser maßnahme ist eine
sehr abschreckende botschaft an alle
investoren der schaden könnte in mainz
ein und wozu das ganze nun und wieder
einmal die gleichen alten leute zu
begünstigen mexikos grösster privater
und wird vom staatsunternehmen pemex
betrieben das ergebnis ist dass die
mexikanischen ölgesellschaft trotz aller
probleme zum zeitpunkt als am 9 die
macht kam immerhin noch 1,8 millionen
barrels fördert heute liegt diese zahl
bei 1,6 millionen und alles deutet
darauf hin dass es nicht viel besser
werden wird
[Musik]
die mexikanische wirtschaft ist schon
eine ziemliche claudia star aber eine
bestimmte sache raab selbst aus dieser
als besonders gaga heraus die tatsache
dass ein land das über so große
ölvorkommen verfügt gezwungen ist
kraftstoffe zu importieren bei seiner
raffinerien teilweise noch aus dem
neunzehnten jahrhundert stammen aber gut
auch diese unglaublichen rückständigkeit
will am loh irgendwie beheben sein
problem ist nur dass all das irgendwie
auch finanziert werden muss und bisher
wurden mehr als sechs milliarden dollar
dafür ausgegeben um shell seinen anteil
an einer raffinerie in texas aufzukaufen
eine raffinerie an der pemex sowieso
schon beteiligt war und danach blieb
kaum noch geld um die raffinerien des
staatlichen ölkonzerns wenigstens
notdürftig zu modernisieren und welchen
sinn macht es für viel geld eine
partnerschaft mit shell zu beenden die
eigentlich gut funktioniert hat wenn per
mac seine eigenen anlagen so schlecht
wartet und verwaltet ganz einfach gar
keinen aber wartet mal denn das ist
praktisch gar nichts im vergleich zu den
fast 0 milliarden dollar die am loh für
eines seiner star projekte aus gibt den
bau einer raffinerie in seinem
heimatstaat tabasco aus denen auch der
treffer für die gleichnamige kruse kommt
und in diesem fall lässt am nicht zu
dass ich irgendetwas zwischen pemex und
mexikos selbstversorgung bei der
kraftstoffproduktion stellt und wenn ich
nichts sage versichere ich euch das
amilo absolute nichts meint der max baut
einer raffinerie in einem
naturschutzgebiet das es zu schützen
versprochen hat der punkt ist also dass
die mexikanische regierung ist alle
register zieht um sicherzustellen dass
das land bis 2023 seinen kompletten
kraftstoffbedarf selbst produzieren kann
das problem ist jedoch dass sie dabei
wieder gesehen haben eine philosophie
folgt mit der mexiko schon seit
jahrzehnten immer wieder das ist erdöl
nationalismus und jede menge
interventionismus ohne rücksicht auf
wirtschaftliche kriterien und man muss
wahrlich kein großer prophet sein um das
ergebnis auch diese reform vorherzusagen
und das ergebnis ist immer wieder
riesiges elend und meist auch viele
viele tote stadt den ölreichtum dazu zu
verwenden die menschen endlich aus der
armut und drogen kriminalität zu
befreien wird munter weiter
experimentiert die zahl der morde ist
unter am loh auf den höchsten stand seit
31 jahren gestiegen und lag 2020 bei
fast
37.000 todesopfern das entspricht
eigentlich schon einem kriegsgebiet aber
das ist ein thema für ein ganz eigenes
video lasst uns ist das thema unseres
videos mit dem stromsektor abschließen
denn verlässliche stromversorgung ist
eine stabile wirtschaft den wohlstand
der bevölkerung und ja auch ihre
sicherheit vor kriminalität ein
wichtiger faktor nun ja und im
stromsektor geht es in mexiko bisher
auch drunter und drüber deswegen erst am
loh in der wichtigsten pfeiler seiner
monumentalen energiereform fünf worden
ist denn wie wir gleich sehen werden
fügt sich seinen plan erst unter
berücksichtigung des strommarktes zu
einem großen bild zusammen erst dann
werden wir verstehen welche interessen
politik wirklich hinter seiner agenda
steckt also aufgepasst
eine verfassungsreform in eigener sache
die verstaatlichung von 1960 machte auch
sieben gesamten mexikanische stromsektor
ein staatliches monopol in den händen
des staatsunternehmens
cfds blieb ist in den 90er jahre so als
eine zaghafte öffnung hinz und
privatsektor stattfand es wurde das
sogenannte selbst versorgungsmodell
eingeführt ein mechanismus lässt
unternehmen ermöglichte die csu umgehen
und strom von kraftwerken private
energieversorger im rahmen von
großabnehmer verträgen einzukaufen die
öffnung für den privatsektor gewann mit
ping an eto'os eine reform an schwung
sie kurbelte die investition in der
stromerzeugung an es wurde ein großer
witz markt für strom eingerichtet der
den billigsten und erneuerbaren energie
versorger den vorrang einräumt das
klingt doch alles ganz gut nicht wahr
nun nicht in den ohren am los wären peña
nieto die cd in den hintergrund drängte
mit mitteilung einen großen teil seiner
bemühungen im jahr 2021 umsetzung einer
elektrizitäts reform welche cd also der
regierung stärken sollte
so sagte ando strom reformer große
kontroversen weise die reihenfolge der
energieverteilung in kraftwerken änderte
an erster stelle würden die wasserkraft
öl und kohle kraftwerke der cse in
betrieb geht ein zweiter stelle stehen
die gaskombikraftwerke die ihre energie
auch für die cfw erzeugt nach diesen
anlagen würden private wind und
solarenergie passfolgen und schließlich
die gaskombikraftwerke privater
unternehmen
aber welche logik steckt dahinter ich
meine wer käme auf die idee den fossilen
brennstoffen den vorrang vor
erneuerbaren energien zu gehen wind und
sonnen müssen genutzt werden wenn es
wind und sonne gibt erst wenn sie mal
nicht zur verfügung stehen sollten die
grundlast gegen kraftwerke übernehmen
das ist das einmaleins der moderne
stromerzeugung und so sah es auch ein
mexikanisches gericht welches am los
schon vor monaten beschlossene reform
kippte in einem land mit
rechtssicherheit wäre das das ende der
strom reform gewesen aber nicht in am
los mexiko
mexikos präsident droht mit einer
verfassungsänderung falls das strom
gesetz gekippt wird das problem für den
mexikanischen präsidenten ist dass der
technisch gesehen keine ausreichende
mehrheit hat um die verfassungsänderung
durchzubringen er greift also zu
bürokratischen tricks
[Musik]
jetzt ist nicht mehr von einer speise
verordnung die rede sondern von quoten
das ziel bleibt das gleiche die
kraftwerke der csu soll 54 prozent des
mexikanischen stroms produzieren und an
dieser stelle fragst du dich vielleicht
wozu eigentlich dieser ganze aufwand was
steckt da dahinter und im grunde
genommen geht es darum dass im jahr 2020
eine neue internationale verordnung in
kraft trat diese begrenzen den
schwefelgehalt im treibstoff für schiffe
und bis dahin war dies einer der
hauptmärkte für das von den pemex
raffinerien produzierte schon der öl
diese sind so veraltet dass sie nicht in
der lage sind den schwefelgehalt des
schweröls zu senken und das und nichts
anderes ist das ziel von am loh die
wärme kraft sagte der csu sondern das
dreckige schweröl verbrennen dass
niemand von pemex kaufen will dies wird
nicht nur zu grauenvoller
umweltverschmutzung sondern ist
obendrein auch noch wirtschaftlicher
irrsinn denn die erzeugungskosten liegen
25 prozent höher als bei neuen
erneuerbaren kraftwerken mit anderen
worten am loh ist es egal ob mexiko
teure und schmutzige energie produziert
das einzige was ihn interessiert ist
jenes mexikanischen straße unternehmen
in welchem er seine amigos lukrative
pöstchen verschafft hat um jeden preis
zu privilegieren und wenn das am ende
bedeuten sollte dass man die
subventionen braucht damit die
stromrechnung die mexikaner nicht noch
weiter steigen dann leihen wir uns das
geld eben oder drucken ist einfach
selbst aber falls ihr es denkt dicker
könnte es nicht mehr kommen dann haltet
euch jetzt lieber fest
[Musik]
mit anders reform wird mexiko nicht nur
teure und schmutzige energie produzieren
sondern durch diesen markt satz herren
interventionismus auch zahlreiche
investitionsvorhaben gefährden dazu
zählen bitter notwendige investitionen
in wind und solarenergie im wert von
über 40 milliarden dollar genauso wie
der ausbau der förderkapazitäten erdöl
und dieses zu den nun hochgradig
lukrativen preisen auf dem weltmarkt zu
exportieren wo es russisches öl ersetzen
würde wenn an los gesetze verabschiedet
würden werden in mexiko produzieren der
internationale automobil luft- und
raumfahrt medizintechnik und elektronik
hersteller gezwungen seien von einem
staatlichen monopolisten schmutzigen
teuren und weniger zuverlässigen strom
zu beziehen und die us regierung wird
einen anderen ersatz für ölimporte
senken müssen da am loh die rohre
exporte bis 2023 stoppen will um zum
einen diesen schmutzigen strom zu
erzeugen und zum anderen die
einheimische produktion von benzin und
diesel auszubauen all das ist
besorgniserregend von mexikos zukunft
wenn es versteckt noch mal die tendenz
des rückgangs an investitionen seit
amtsantritt damit verpasst mexiko eine
riesenchance es wäre mit seiner
volkswirtschaftlichen struktur
eigentlich wie gemacht dafür einer der
hauptprofiteure des aktuellen globalen
megatrends zu sein der abkehr der
weltwirtschaft von china und russland
multinationale unternehmen werden sich
in den nächsten jahren immer mehr von
diesen beiden staaten unabhängig machen
wollen so groß sind mittlerweile die mit
ihnen verbundenen risiken bei russland
geht es hauptsächlich um die
substitution des erdöls aus anderen
förderländern und china und die
diversifizierung einrichtungen der
lieferkette weg vom roten riesen und
hinein in anderer standorte mit
ähnlicher oder günstigere lohnstruktur
für mexiko könnte dies eine goldene
gelegenheit sein die chance des
jahrhunderts ein sprungbrett aus dem
elend in die liga der entwickelten
länder aber leider leider trauen die
investoren den mexikanischen präsidenten
nicht über den weg und die daten
sprechen für sich
[Musik]
aber an dieser stelle ist die frage an
euch gerichtet haltet ihr es richtig den
interessen der staatlichen unternehmens
vorrang für erneuerbare energie und für
internationale investoren zu geben was
haltet ihr von den reformen die am loh
durchgeführt hat könnte mexiko doch noch
irgendwie auf den zug der aktuellen
megatrends aufspringen der immer sind
sie auf eure beiträge und diskussion zu
diesem thema schon sehr gespannt ich
hoffe also dass euch dieses video
gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht auch
etwas gelernt habt fast jahr gibt es nun
ein leichtes mit euren freunden
vergessen ist auch mit glöckchen und
keines unseren videos mehr zu verpassen
natürlich freuen dass auch jederzeit
über die spende von euch mediums hält
dieses projekt weiterzuführen den paper
link dazu findet dieser beschreibung und
eine video was gut und bis bald
[Musik]